are you prepared to stand trial and
profess your guilt or innocence before
the seven we need to trust each other so
many enemies now praise and the
Lannisters send their regard you knew
they wanted tell them what you did to it
are you afraid good you're in the great
game in the great games terrifying
you
hey guys p peppers here that was the
episode 10 for season 6 trailer that I
just had in the beginning and we're
going to break it down so we'll see you
know what to expect in this season
finale last night we had the Battle of
bastards and we know what's going on in
the north and what is going on in marine
and so now we'll see what's going on in
King's Landing at least by the way we
start out and as you know like most of
them episode 9 s of the big crazy action
but the season finales have some lot of
you know tying up loose ends and there
have been some pretty crazy things that
have happened so let's see what we have
here our first images of Circe in her
quarters in the red keep here she's
getting ready and we have to imagine
it's for her trial not much she has to
do she's pretty much cut off from
everybody and she's just scheming away
to get out of this now we'll talk about
in the predictions later a little bit
more about that but for now she's
obviously going to face her trial so now
we have a couple quick shots of Marjorie
getting ready and then we have Tom and
getting ready and we're expecting
they're also going to the trial and we
have this super whoa shot of the high
Sparrow getting ready and then we see a
you know that what this looks like you
can see that the public's there we have
seven Church clergy who will be the who
will be judging the the trials and like
I said we can normally just guess but it
seems like they're going to do all of
them in one big spectacle cleaning some
house and you know it's hard to tell
where all the different characters are
gonna end up as far as things go but the
one thing that they keep in mind is that
the high Sparrow definitely seemed like
you wanted Margaery and Tommen to have a
child because that keeps the faith
militant in power that's you know
seriously gave them that power and
that's where all the
mess started again so I think that I
think that even if they find Sarah see
you know guilty of some of the other
things they're not really going to find
her guilty of incest because if Tommen
left the throne then what would they do
let me get Loras we get a shot of him
the High Septon seems to be the arm here
asking him maybe to confess or telling
him what his charges are and you know on
some levels the teams like Loras could
be the sacrificial lamb they mean it's
sort of like that you know they have all
this power they have all this spectacle
and they kind of need to bring somebody
down but I think Cersei is also going to
get some sort of craziness so like in
the books I would think that Loras would
probably be able to confess and you know
take the black but I don't know about
the show it might just be you know one
of those crazy shocking moments that
they have set up or they want something
bad to happen to someone or you know it
I mean it's just it's just sort of hard
to tell like he the obviously Marjorie
is playing ball and pretending like
she's really you know on the side of the
faith but we know that she's not because
she passed the you know the note to her
grandmother and you know told her to
leave town so she couldn't get caught up
in this so you know the it's it could
really go either way with with those
guys people are obviously guilty and
it's just a matter of how they're going
to you know end up so this was my
favorite part of the trailer it's the
white Raven headed to Winterfell and if
you're not familiar with the Citadel and
what the Ravens you know that they use
they only use the white Ravens to signal
the change of the seasons so it's pretty
symbolic you know the white Raven is
flying to Winterfell to announce that
winter has started so you know the name
of the show the name of the episode is
when
winter and there's a big scene that that
involves the white Raven in the books
I'm not sure if it's going to go that
way but this could be a symbol of
something else is happening in King's
Landing with Barris or it could be you
know just to show that things are
different now when I winner it's here
even though they won the battle and the
north things will never kind of be the
same and then we see you know John and
Santa they're having a thing about
having a conversation about trust and
she is seeming to be still holding
things back not you know one hundred
percent sure and if you remember in the
beginning you know Sansa and John were
never close as siblings especially if
you read the books you know Santa always
always referred to John as her
half-brother and she was really you know
the one who was super into the idea of
like trueborns and the difference and
you know like John was much closer with
the all the other siblings so I don't
know if they're they're trying to point
that out or if they're just trying to
show that you know they're in a tough
situation and you know luckily they got
this back but they're going to have to
trust each other for the future then we
get old scumbag Walder Frey and if you
don't remember he was the guy who
betrayed the Starks with Roose Bolton
and had held the red wedding in this
exact same location helo through there
also from the last episode and we see
Jamie he's there they got river run back
the phrase should be pretty happy at
this point not really sure what Jamie's
doing I mean according to his dialogue
in the land you know this season he is
trying to get back to Cersei but things
are you know a bit different in his
story and the book so this is another
thing that I'm going to talk about in
predictions but I feel like this is kind
of maybe like if we're following show
logic and
I'm just throwing out some of the other
stuff in the book that this might sort
of start being it's like starting to
make sense a little bit so so then we
have a nice scene in the in the godswood
at Winterfell by the heart tree sonses
their little finger approaches and she
asks what do you want and he replies I
thought you knew what I want and you
know if we just go off of the actual
words there what he wants his power it's
always been that and he's been pretty
clear about you know making that known
to her there's a little bit of an
insinuation that it might be that I want
you to marry me and you know we can rule
together obviously he was obsessed with
her mom as a child and married her and
to get you know get the power that he
has right now but I'm not sure that that
would probably just be some ongoing
tension you know I don't really see
those two characters ending up together
but I do you know I mean it's clearly
obvious that he wants to be as powerful
as possible and she's you know I mean I
don't know there's not really much in
her way because no one knows brands
alive in order for her to be at least
temporarily in charge of the north as
far as Winterfell is involved in you
know we don't really know what's going
to happen with John but they're right
now they're an alliance and you know for
some weird reason little finger and
songs also our alliance so there are two
separate things are not altogether and
I'm not sure that they will all you know
meld anytime soon so then we get this
the scene where we have Melisandre John
and Davao stavos found out finally that
what happened to Shireen you know I
found the little stag and the thyre
where you know where she was burned
alive and you know and the clip he's
he's shouting at Melisandre to tell John
what he what he what she did
you know she has kind of a down-and-out
look on her face like she has had for
most of the season so like what you know
for 1 i'm not really sure what their you
know what is what is he asking John is
he want John to you know get rid of her
Vanisher killer I mean it's hard to say
you know like John first of all John you
know just did a terrible job I mean this
is kind of I'm kind of saying this as a
joke but he just did a terrible job as
leading that are of that leading the
army against the Bolton so like you know
I don't really I mean I guess he still
has cred as far as you know coming back
from the dead but they haven't really
been emphasizing that much and
Melisandre is the person that brought
him back so it's like you know I don't
know I really don't know what Douglas is
asking for here as far as I mean
obviously he's asking for justice for
Shireen but at the same time these three
are kind of in bed together and there's
you know I don't know what the how this
resolves Melisandre doesn't seem to you
know doesn't seem to deny it or anything
like that i liked it's obviously known
that that's what happened you know just
a just a really quick idea is like well
she could obviously say that she had to
give shiur eens life to bring John back
and then that would make everything
hunky-dory we get a really quick shot of
brand as you can see he's still up north
we didn't expect him to be anywhere else
and he looks to be by tree so he could
be you know accessing some visions we
imagine that he's still fine he's got
Mira and uncle Benjen who is the show's
equivalent of cold hands so you know
don't expect him I don't really expect
him to be in much danger in this scene
at least from this look of it but I feel
like he's you know this is probably tied
together to either the the reveal about
the tower joy or about just the general
movements and
you know the threat that the White
Walkers pose I mean I kind of you know
two weeks ago I didn't think that they
would end the season without addressing
both of those things so I not much has
changed to make me change my mind but I
feel like we're going to get an idea
about I mean there has to be something
about the White Walkers this is this is
coming into the last you know season and
a half basically so hopefully we'll get
a little idea of what where they're at
what's going on and also the payoff for
the Tower of joy of course this could be
something that they teased until next
season but um again we'll talk about
that in predictions to but brands that
you know but you know the this shot was
so short like if you flinch your eyes
you wouldn't notice it doesn't show
anything else and even though this is
probably one of the most interesting
storylines for me that not a whole lot
that you can tell from this then we got
a shot of dario talking to Danny and you
know my guess here is that she's leaving
him in murine so she's telling him
goodbye she's getting ready to go off it
would be kind of consistent with things
that happen to the book they're not the
same obviously but you know she has she
has strong feelings for him but she also
wants to rule and she knows that's her
destiny so she doesn't really foresee
staying with him obviously he you know
she can't marry him you know because
he's not of the right standing and all
that so I think that's where that clip
with that clip points to she needs to
someone to you know take care of marine
she has really been concerned about that
that's why she's not in Westeros already
she sees those people as their children
that she freed so he would be the
perfect person to stay behind and take
care of that and we just get this random
mystery guy I'm not sure what it is not
sure what he's doing could be Lancel or
could be you know the guy the last wise
master that's still alive hard to tell
it's just the back of the head if you
have an idea please tell me who you
think
is in our last little clip is tyrion and
he's given Danny a pep talk about going
to Westeros and um this is pretty
straightforward not really sure if Danny
will leave in this episode but she's
definitely getting prepared to she has
the Ironborn behind her she has the
slaver ships and she has her counsel
Tyrion Plus let's not forget the dragon
so she's pretty much ready to go and he
seems to be just giving her a pep talk
and you know it saying that you're
scared that's normal it's a scary thing
let's do this so as far as predictions
go I think we've all kind of learned a
lesson as far as these wild fan theories
and things that we see coming up and
learn that for the most part what you
think the simplest explanation is
probably the right one and the example
of this would be in the last episode you
know I was kind of thinking all week
what's the big twist going to be what's
the big twist going to be because it
seemed too simple for Littlefinger to
show up even though we knew that he you
know we sent the raven and everything
and that was likely to happen I figured
there'd be some other big twist but you
know what there wasn't that's what
happened is little finger showed up and
the Bolton army was defeated Little John
members done and so on and so forth so
as far as predictions go I think one of
the big things is the trial like I said
earlier I don't know that we can expect
too much beyond what what seems obvious
I mean they're guilty they're going to
be found guilty I would expect that the
that it'll be fixed in the sense that
Cersei won't be found guilty of incest
and that Tommen will stay on the throne
that said it all the other obvious thing
that seems to be coming up is this idea
of wildfire and her destroying the city
you know there's that scene that we saw
way back in season 2 episode 10 where
Danny sees King's Landing and thrown
rooms all burnt down and you know sir
she does have her back against the wall
one hundred percent so we can imagine
that she's not just going to take that
lying down and she doesn't have anybody
that's on her side anymore except Kai
burn and Kai burn is just the kind of
guy who could help facilitate setting
off the wildfire that's below the great
cept and Kings Landing in general so I
do think that's going to happen will it
happen at the end of this episode I feel
like there's a pretty good chance and I
just don't see any other way out for her
and again you know most of the [ __ ] you
know most of the the show isn't as big
on foreshadowing but they have
definitely foreshadowed this wildfire
for a while and you know in the books
it's backed up quite a bit by her how
crazy she actually is towards the end
and she does burn down the Tower of the
hand with wildfire at one point which
you know that hasn't been in the show
but you know there's a there's a there's
a history of her burning [ __ ] down so I
think that'll probably happen not really
sure about Loras I'm sure Marjorie is
not going to let them be a sacrificial
lamb quietly so you know that there's a
lot of things that could happen there
the other two that I think are you know
important to keep in mind when you're
watching and you're thinking about
what's going to happen is brand and the
phrase sobran is like I say I think he
will he'll give us some insight into
what's coming for next season I think
that's you know we're going to see we're
going to see Danny getting ready to come
over we know that's going to happen
we're going to see things come to an end
in King's Landing and then that's all
just set up really for the big battle
with the White Walkers and you know I
think bran will give us some insight
into that will he give us some insight
into jon snow's parentage it's possible
i mean they know the fans want to know
that i don't know how important it is
based on where we're at and things right
now but obviously you know fans will
enjoy that of all types you know it's
it's a big question it's something
that's important and then the phrase and
this is where i was talking sort of
about the Riverlands come in and
actually kind of making sense like last
episode you know they're really there
was they brought back these old story
lines and it wasn't really a great
episode especially the Riverlands part
and you know i just dawned on me
whenever and obviously
the Arias storyline was pretty
unsatisfying how to end up in Braavos so
then it just occurred to me that maybe
the reason that these things are there
are so that Aria could get to the
Riverlands and take a person off of her
list and that would be Walder Frey I
believe I think that's pretty likely to
happen I think that there's you know if
you take all the book stuff out of your
mind and you just look at what the
show's been doing and you just follow
show logic I think there's a pretty good
case that Aria wasn't there for no
reason she was there to be trained as an
assassin and she has this list Walder
Frey's on her list and Walder Frey is
right there in the Riverlands so if
she's headed back to Westeros perhaps
first she'll go to the Riverlands and
she will dispatch a Walder Frey and that
will cause some chaos now how that'll
affect the Jamie storyline not really
sure because I expect him to go back to
King's Landing that's what he said he
wanted to do and you know there's a lot
of things that could come from their
side I don't really expect him to just
get stuck in the Riverlands either so
maybe he'll leave before she'll show up
take care of him and then everything
will be messed up and you know that
would also tie in to the fact that you
have the Brotherhood there I know Derek
you or ya there Barrick used to be on
her list I don't think he is anymore but
you know that those storylines could
kind of converge on that moving all back
towards the north at that point some
other things to think about I think we
haven't seen veras variant with the
white Raven it brings up the end of the
dance with dragons the book in it brings
up the idea of how he rolls in and
assassinates a few key players that
could happen I kind of hope it will
happen but he could also be doing other
stuff that's that's unrelated and you
know sir see this whole idea of her
burning down the city
is obviously going to lead to the end of
our character at some point but you know
don't forget about the Maggy the Frog
the mage ease prophecy because it's been
really important and how Searcy has has
a you know made all of her decisions for
quite a long time and you know she all
of her children are supposed to die
before she does and then she's supposed
to be killed by the violent core which
is a younger brother and we know that
Jamie was born after her so both Tyrion
and Jaime are younger brothers so I
don't think we're going to see that
happening I mean you know it could but I
think we're really going to get the
groundwork laid for everything moving
forward in the future and I think that
the most doable thing is the whole
Walder Frey aria thing so we didn't see
them like I said we didn't see Barris so
we don't really know but they're not
going to show everything that's going to
happen and you know so we know for sure
is that these trials are going to happen
and we don't know what how that's going
to end up but like the sparrow the
sparrow is not going to come away clean
and it's probably unlikely these going
to come away alive so we'll see what
happens so let me know what you think
leave some comments if you have any
other questions I might make a video
about episode 10 once it's complete if I
have time so I'll talk to you then
please like the video and subscribe